The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: So.
Today's lecture is partly
cleaning up some pieces
left from 1-D problems.
3.1 was second
order equations, 3.2
was fourth order
equations for beams.
And just a few more
comments to make.
But then I do want to say
something about splines.
And I included a
homework question that
asked you to use the spline
command and get a result.
I'm not planning to make that
a serious topic in the course.
In other words,
you're not like going
to be responsible on an exam
for a discussion of splines.
But it's such a major event, and
major requirement in scientific
computing -- if you're
given some values,
put a curve through them -- that
I have to say something about
that.
So that's interpolation.
Because you'll have
this all the time.
If your experiment
produces some values
at specific times or a
finite number of values,
and you want to fit a
curve through those points.
How do you do it?
So splines give a
very, very good answer.
And then, the next and
big topic of the course
we'll make a beginning on.
Which is gradient, divergence,
leading to Laplace's equation.
Problems in 2-D. So partial
differential equations
are going to show up.
OK.
Some small points.
First point, about the
MATLAB homework for Monday.
A question came by email.
I put the spike and also the
jump in c, in the coefficient,
not at mesh point.
If you've started
on that problem,
you probably noticed that,
and maybe a little swearing
went on. [LAUGHTER] Because
it makes it not so easy.
And then the question
came, did I really
expect you to compute,
use the exact position
and figure out-- When you
have some integrals to do,
they'll change at the place
where c changes values.
Where we have integrals of c,
if c has one of those jumps,
on the quiz the jump came
right at a neat point,
so it was clear. c was one on
one side and two on the other.
Now the jump is going to
come at an in-between point.
So the answer is yes.
I had a nice email this
morning from somebody who
has done that MATLAB homework.
And he said, quote,
it's a good problem.
I learned more from it than
I did from the other problems
in the pset.
So I'll blame it on him.
I'll stay with that
problem, and ask
you to do your best to
deal with the calculation.
It's second order and
I used linear elements.
I didn't want to push you
up to these cubic elements,
even though those would
give much better accuracy.
One reason I didn't put the
spike and the jump right
at the node is that, if I did,
the finite element solution
would be exactly right.
Because the correct solution is
going to be piecewise linear.
And if I put the breaks between
pieces right at node points,
well, then I have a function
that's in my finite element
space, in my linear space.
So it'll come out exactly.
So I thought well, let's
at least have some chance
to see the error between
the finite element
solution and the exact one.
You see what I'm saying?
I'm just anticipating,
that the exact solution
will-- Let's see.
Something happened at 1/3 and
something happened at 2/3.
I'm afraid I don't remember
the boundary conditions.
Does anybody remember what I
took for boundary conditions?
Probably free-fixed,
or something.
So maybe, if it was free-fixed,
probably the solution
would be maybe
something like that.
I don't know.
Whatever.
Piecewise linear with breaks
where there's a jump in c,
or where the point
load is hitting.
Yeah.
I don't know if that
picture is accurate.
But my point was, if I chose
those points to be also mesh
points, then the finite element
solution would be exact,
and we wouldn't learn
anything about accuracy.
OK.
So anyway, for that
MATLAB problem,
I'm hoping you can do
the integrals, which
will mean noticing which
integral-- If that doesn't
fall, so if the mesh
points are like this,
in the finite element
integral over that mesh,
over that interval,
you're going to have
to split it into two pieces.
That's it.
So see if you can do that split,
do the split into two pieces.
OK.
So that's a comment
on that homework.
OK.
What else do I need
to comment on, when
I'm sort of catching up here?
Oh, about boundary conditions.
I thought I would
just repeat clearly
on the board the rules
about and the difference
between fixed and free when
we're doing this weak form
approach to the problem.
And then I gave the other
names: a fixed condition,
in this theory it's often
called an essential boundary
condition, but many
people just name
Dirichlet as the person's
name that's associated
with such conditions.
Like u(0)=0.
Right, fixed.
And then free conditions
are natural conditions
in the finite element
method, and that
means that we don't
have to impose them.
Right.
I discussed this in
the earlier lecture.
I just thought I'd
bring it back here,
because it's easy to
describe in one line.
Now somebody asked, on
Wednesday, a good question.
Suppose u' is given,
but not given as zero.
So suppose we have a condition
like u'=A, let's say.
What to do?
So I'll just put question mark.
How do I deal with-- How do I?
How does the weak form approach
and the Galerkin approach
deal with a non-zero,
natural condition?
A non-zero Neumann condition,
that'd be the right word.
So this would be, in a
second order problem,
this would be a
Neumann condition.
And I'm thinking, what do
you do if A isn't zero.
Somehow that has to show up in
your finite element equations,
right?
So I guess the right
way is to go back
to the way they came from.
So you remember how
the weak form came?
I took the
differential equation,
I multiplied by
any test function,
and I integrated by parts.
That's where the
weak form started.
So the integration
by parts gave me
this nice symmetric integral.
It's symmetric in
u and v. It only
requires one derivative
of u, so that I'm
allowed to use hat functions.
And I'm allowed to use
hat functions for v,
because their derivatives
have just a jump,
and a jump function I can
integrate, no problem.
Now what about this u'=A?
And I guess we're
seeing it there.
If u' was zero, if we
had a totally free end,
u' was zero, nothing
happening there,
then that term would drop out
of the integration by parts.
And you see why I don't
have to impose anything
on v, because that term
is already accounted
for by the u' going away.
Now, what about if u' is
given, but not given zero?
Suppose it's given the
value A. All I want to say
is, then this term has to stay.
I have to pay attention to it.
What happens when
Galerkin takes over?
Galerkin will put in one
of his test functions.
Maybe I just indicate that
by changing the v to a cap V.
It'll be one of them.
There'll be n of them.
Each V_i, each test guy,
gives me an equation.
And of course u is now going
to-- The Galerkin idea is that
instead of any u, I
only have capital U's.
Combinations of these phis.
I'm not going to say anything
very big here, or very clear.
All I want to say is that if u
prime is given at an end point,
and given by A, then this whole
stuff is equaling something
with an f, right?
f*V_i*dx.
I should remember the
other side of the equation.
If u' is given, then
c at that end point,
times the given value of
A, times the V will be --
whatever value of V that is
-- will show up in equation i.
That will be a term that
goes on the right-hand side.
That's all I'm saying,
and all you would expect.
That any time I'm
given some data,
I'm given some non-zero
boundary conditions,
or I'm given some
non-zero f in the inside,
that stuff is going to show
up on the right-hand side.
It'll show up as part of
the F. The vector of these.
So up to now, F has just come
from little f(x), integrated
against V. And all I'm
saying is that if we
had one of these guys, then
that would contribute to big F,
also.
Yeah.
You can see, it's not beautiful.
But we have to realize
what we would do.
OK, that's not my
favorite topic.
But I'll just say
quit on that one.
I'm not expecting you to do
problems or anything that
involved that possibility.
Just to see that
it could happen.
OK.
Quit.
Now, interpolation.
All right.
So I guess if I had
to list problems
that people face all the time
and need numerical guidance on,
this is one of them.
And so let's say we're in 1-D
-- 1-D is certainly a lot easier
-- so, suppose I have this.
I'll call this x, just to
have a name for the variable.
Suppose I have some values.
Say six values.
And I've measured
them, I've worked hard
to find those six values.
But now you may say,
well I'm thinking
I have some function F(x) here.
But right now I don't
have a function.
Right now I just have six
values of that function.
You know, what is the stretching
constant, what is the c(x).
If you had a physical experiment
with an actual spring,
you might measure, you might
put on different forces
and measure the stretching,
and have six values of that.
How do I fit those with a curve?
In other words, how do I know--
Interpolation means, inter-
means asking, what about
between the points?
What value should it have there?
OK, well there's one
simple rule would be,
just interpolate
linearly between.
OK.
That's certainly pretty stable.
It will not get out of control.
But it's not very accurate.
For the function that's
probably lying behind this,
this isn't that great
of a representation.
OK, you say, I want
something smoother.
Well another idea that
naturally comes up
is, the other extreme would be--
So that was completely local.
Just, every two values
determine the broken line.
The second idea that's
completely natural
would be, fit a polynomial.
Fit a polynomial
through those points,
and then you have a nice,
totally simple function.
Nice curve.
And so what degree polynomial
would we be looking for here?
If I have six points, I could
fit a polynomial of degree--
What do you think?
I want to have six
coefficients, so I
can get six equations to
make the polynomial go
through those six points.
So my polynomial
P(x), which actually
goes through those points, would
be some polynomial of the form,
it's got some constant term,
and it's got some linear term.
And how far am I going to go?
Fifth, right.
That'll give me
six coefficients.
OK.
So I could put a fifth
degree polynomial, that
gives me a_0, a_1, up to a_5.
Six coefficients
through six points.
Well, six isn't too bad.
But if six became
60, don't do it.
That's the message.
Don't do it.
If I'm going on up to, say I
have an a_59 x to the 59th,
And that fits my 60 points.
And you say, well look,
I've got 60 values,
that should be way better
than having only six.
But the polynomial that
would come out of that,
even if these values
were pretty smooth,
the polynomial that fits -- well
I'd have to put in a whole lot
more to get 60,
and I won't try --
the polynomial would go crazy.
Can I just draw something crazy?
I mean, whatever.
It's unstable.
And there are classical
examples of that.
In fact, the famous example
is the function one over one
plus x squared.
And later, there's a figure
in the book, I think it's
in section 5.4, which
shows the result.
That's a terrific function.
It's infinitely differentiable.
I would even call it
an analytic function.
It's great.
But if I tried to fit it
with a high-degree polynomial
at points, that polynomial
gets out of hand.
And a figure is in--
the figure there.
So, MATLAB or any
computing system
would have a subroutine
that does interpolation.
And this is named
after Lagrange.
So this is called
Lagrange interpolation,
fitting a polynomial.
And if the degree is small,
and maybe degree five
would be okay, then
that's an important thing
to be able to do.
In other words, you're
finding these six coefficients
from these six heights.
You've got some six by six
matrix that connects the six
heights to the six a's.
But when you get up to 60, that
matrix stops behaving well.
It becomes very ill conditioned,
and your coefficients
go all over the place.
OK, so my question
is, what do you do?
And one answer, one good
answer is fit those points
not with straight lines,
that's too crude; not
with a single polynomial,
that's too unstable;
but fit it with splines.
So interpolation by splines.
OK.
So it's just sort of
appearing in this section
3.2-- I mean by that,
and people often do mean,
when they say spline,
they mean cubic spline.
So you could have
splines of other degrees.
But often, sort of the
natural choice is the cubic.
So can I just briefly
describe what that does.
What the cubic
spline would be like.
So let me draw in
again these six points
that I'm going to fit.
And just say, for these few
minutes, what's a cubic spline.
I touched on that
Wednesday, and now
I just want to say
a little bit more.
And then the homework
asked you to actually do it
with values of a
particular function.
And see how close does
the cubic spline come
to the given function.
OK, so what's a cubic spline?
What does that
word, spline, what
should that mean in your mind?
So a cubic spline is
a cubic in each piece.
A cubic in each piece.
Now we've met cubics in each
piece as finite elements.
And part of this
short discussion
is to keep those two slightly
different ideas separate.
The finite element idea
was also piecewise cubic.
But it used values and slopes.
So it was completely local.
If I had a value, as I
have here, six values,
and if I also had six slopes,
if I knew the slopes, then
I would use those
cubic elements.
And I would fit a-- If I knew
the height and slope there,
and I knew the height
and slope there,
there would be
exactly one cubic.
Because I would have
four conditions,
two conditions there,
would be four.
I could fit a cubic between,
another cubic there,
another cubic there.
And because I'm using the
same slope from the left
and from the right, the
slope would be good.
It would be continuous.
The second derivative,
the curvature,
would not be continuous
with those cubic elements.
And that's the difference.
So the difference is,
splines have continuous,
no jump in-- Let me
just put it this way.
No jump in the function.
I'll use S, maybe, for spline.
No jump in its slope.
And no jump in the
second derivative.
So that's the difference.
That the spline
functions, the only
jumps you see for those are
jumps in the third derivative.
So that makes this
extremely smooth.
So if I just try to draw
now what a spline would do,
it'll go through those points,
coming out of the spline fit
MATLAB command.
And it'll be as
smooth as I drew it.
There is a change in the third
derivative at these points.
Actually, have you ever seen
this word, "spline," before?
It came out of
naval engineering.
When people were designing
the shape of the ship.
A naval architect is fitting
the proposed shape of a ship--
this was before MATLAB,
yeah, before life started.
[LAUGHTER] They had
little physical, slightly
bendable-- I'll
call them splines.
I guess that's what they were.
That's where the word came from.
Some physical thing which was
like a curve that you use-- I
don't know if you guys ever
did mechanical drawing.
That was a freshman
subject when I came to MIT.
Mechanical drawing.
I was terrible, terrible,
at mechanical drawing.
I don't know.
I had a friend who helped.
l probably helped him
in some other course.
Anyway, whatever.
So there were physical things,
curves you used to use.
And these spline
curves were used,
and maybe still are
used, by naval architects
in creating a drawing.
But I'm assuming that
those things are now
all computerized, and the
spline command is used.
Anyway, the result is that.
Now, I have to draw one
picture of a spline.
Of the most important spline.
And then I'm done with splines.
So, what I'm going to
draw is now a B-spline.
And that's a basic spline.
It could be one
of our functions,
it could be one of
our functions phi(x).
One of our trial functions.
It could be, and let
me comment on that.
So let me remind myself,
good or bad, with a question.
And let me try to answer that.
But let me first
draw the B-spline.
OK, so it's like a hat function.
Actually a hat function
is a linear spline.
A hat function is
that low level spline
that's linear between pieces.
Now the B-spline is going
to have the value one there.
It's going to have no
jump in the function.
So the function will
go through there.
No jump in the slope.
No jump in the
second derivative.
And I want to get down to zero.
I want to get down to zero.
I want it to be as
local as I can make it.
So I want it to get to zero.
Here's the point.
With those cubic
finite elements,
I got them down to zero.
They came in here
with zero slope,
and then they continued
as zero, no problem.
If I'm wanting the
second derivative also
to be zero, to be
continuous, I won't be
able to do it in one interval.
It's going to take me a
total of four intervals.
This one can come
down to some point,
here, where another
cubic starts.
Maybe I should do the one here.
Going up, you remember
the allowed cubic spline
would be an x cubed over six,
some multiple of x cubed.
I don't know what multiple it'll
take, maybe x cubed over six
is right.
It'll come up to
some point here.
Now I've got to get it
beginning to curve downwards.
So I'm going to have to
change the third derivative.
Change to another cubic
there, change to another cubic
there, and a final cubic here.
So there's a picture
of a B-spline.
And we could figure out, by
requiring all these continuity
conditions, we could figure
out the formula for the cubic
in these four pieces.
And it would be
symmetric, of course,
across that center point.
But I think I
won't try to do it.
I'll just leave that idea, then.
There's a figure
in the book showing
a picture of the B-spline.
So those are functions,
extremely valuable
in this interpolation problem.
Because all splines are
combinations of B-splines.
Yeah, now let me pull
this topic together.
Every spline, every
spline function,
is combination of
these B-splines.
Let B_i(x) be the one
centered on node i.
And then there's a neighbor
centered on node i+1.
And a neighbor to the
left centered on node i-1.
What's the point?
The point is that, at
a typical node, i+1,
three of these functions
will be non-zero.
With these very local hat
functions at that node,
the only one of the phi
functions that wasn't zero
is the one I've drawn.
All the others were
zero there, right?
All the other hats were zero.
There was just the one.
But now there'll be a
B-spline starting from here,
going up to here,
coming down from here.
There'll be the B-spline
starting from here, going up
to here, up, down, so on.
So at a typical
node, I'm getting
the one centered at
that node, and also
the one to the left,
which is on its way down,
and also the one to the
right, which is on its way up.
In other words,
it's not as local
as the other construction.
So I would say good,
because it's smooth, but bad
because it's not fully local.
Not completely local.
It's reasonably local,
in that there are only
three functions that are
affecting these points.
If I use those polynomials,
they weren't local at all.
All the points, it was--
A typical x to the fifth
is not zero at
any of the points.
These B-splines are
zero at a lot of points,
but three of them,
one, two, and three,
will be non-zero at
a typical mesh point.
OK, so they're not popular, as
a result, for finite elements.
I'm just wanting to be sure
you make the distinction.
They're very popular for
the interpolation job.
I've got some combination
of these at particular mesh
points.
It's supposed to agree with
F at those mesh points.
This is my system to solve.
I create these functions,
these B-splines.
I'm given F at typical points.
And I choose a combination
which matches F at those points.
Yeah, OK.
Is there a question
or discussion on this?
I don't like to not say anything
about such an important problem
as putting curves
through points.
But I don't want to make
it a course on splines.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: I don't
know that I'll-- Oh, OK, yes.
All right.
Two or three comments, and
that suggests a good question,
a very good question.
Can I make a separate
comment that if I
go into two dimensions,
this gets much tougher.
What happens if I had
a function of x and y?
So that I've got
points on a surface,
and I'm trying to
fit a surface to it.
Just one message first:
that's not as easy.
It's pretty easy if those points
are on a rectangular grid.
So this is like typical.
And then I'll come to
your Nyquist question,
which is a very good one.
Can I just-- because we're
coming in to 2-D now.
Suppose I-- There's
two dimensions.
I have a grid.
Let's suppose it's a nice grid.
And at every point, at every
grid point, I have a height.
And I'm fitting a surface.
Right?
My function is now a function of
x and y. x is here, y is here,
F is the surface coming out of
board, in the third dimension.
And fitting those points,
if they're regularly spaced
like that, my life would be OK.
I could use sort of
products of splines in 1-D.
I could use products
of basis-- of splines
in the x-direction times
splines in the y-direction.
And it would be
pretty successful.
It would be, not quite
as nice, but almost OK.
But if I had irregularly spaced
points from a general grid,
it's not as easy.
And I won't-- People have
obviously had to figure out how
to do it, and to repeat again,
that's what the CAD/CAM world
is having to do all the
time, is fit a curve,
fit a surface through points.
It's significant.
Now, you asked about Nyquist.
So that's a good question.
Can I just say, I
have to say what-- So
what's a function called?
Band-limited.
How many have heard
Nyquist's name?
Okay, some of you may know
a lot more than I about it.
But let me just get some context
for band-limited functions.
Okay.
This is actually
a topic that will
belong in the third part of our
course, in the Fourier part.
So this is a Fourier idea.
So I'll come back
to it, actually.
So right here I'm just
going to say, very briefly,
how it might connect us
to what I've said today.
But then let's make
a plan to, when
we've got the idea of
Fourier coefficients.
What is a band-limited function?
You know the Fourier
idea is to take F(x),
and write it as some combination
of pure frequencies. e^(i*K*x),
let me say. e^(i*K*x).
So this is Fourier
that's coming.
I take the function
F(x), and I write it--
I could think of
it as a combination
of pure exponentials,
pure frequencies.
That would be a Fourier series.
So that's a Fourier
series because I'm
using-- K has integer values.
The frequencies are zero,
one, two, three, whatever.
Now that we'll use,
so that Fourier series
comes for functions
that are periodic.
They repeat every 2pi.
Because those functions,
if I increase x by 2pi,
don't change.
So I'm repeating every 2pi.
Now I have to say a word about
the other possibility, which
would be to have
all frequencies.
I'll integrate now, dK.
Instead of summing on
K, I'll integrate on K.
What does band-limited mean?
Band-limited means that only
frequencies in a certain range,
say a range around
zero, are included.
So a band-limited function would
be a function whose frequencies
go from some value, say
minus omega to omega,
instead of going from
minus infinity to infinity.
This would be
band-limited frequencies
between minus omega and omega.
So that's another kind
of smooth function.
That's another
way-- Functions that
have only low frequencies are
associated with smoothness.
High frequencies are associated
with fast oscillations.
So the class of
band-limited functions
gives me another, a Fourier
way, to talk about smoothness.
So for us, smoothness was
something about how many
derivatives were continuous.
That's the sort of
smoothness in the x domain.
How many derivatives.
Smoothness in the
frequency domain
is, how fast do the
frequencies drop off.
And here, band-limited
means they drop like a shot.
Band-limited means that the
frequencies in the function,
that these e^(i*K*x)'s are not
there for high frequencies.
High frequencies are out
for a band-limited function.
And then Shannon has a
formula for the natural way
to fit-- So our same
interpolation problem.
So now, completing the
answer to your question.
So I have these points.
So Shannon could fit a function,
and it would look smooth,
through those points.
And his function
would be band-limited.
So it would be smooth again.
It would be-- yeah,
it would be smooth.
In some way, this Shannon
band-limited stuff
is the limit of splines as
the spline degree goes way up.
So we did hat functions,
degree one splines.
Cubic splines I recommended as
a pretty reliable construction.
But you could do fifth degrees
splines, seventh degree
splines, you could keep going.
And in the limit,
you would get this.
So maybe that's
some partial answer
to the connection between
splines and this Fourier world.
OK.
Thanks.
So these are topics now--
Wow, today's lecture
is kind of-- Can I do one
really important thing now
in today's lecture?
For you to remember?
Gradient and divergence?
I don't want you to
spend the weekend
without thinking about gradient
and divergence. [LAUGHTER] OK.
Here's the idea.
For lots and lots of
applications, for a region,
let's say, in the plane,
I have the same-- What
physical example
shall I pick now?
Maybe I'll let u
be the temperature.
So instead of
being displacement,
let me make it temperature. u.
OK.
Then I have a
temperature gradient.
A slope.
But now, the whole point is,
that's a function of x and y.
Then I have a
temperature gradient.
And if I'm consistent with the
notation, that'll be e(x,y).
And then you'll expect
that there's some c(x,y).
Some operator c that tells
me how much heat flows.
This will tell me
something about the the,
the thermal conductivity.
Right?
Really, as I speak
about this framework,
I'm just uttering
the correct words.
Having started with
temperature, this thing
should be a
temperature gradient.
Then I should have some
physical thermal conductivity,
different for different
metals or different materials.
And I'll have a
heat flow, w(x,y).
And everybody knows that
w will be c times e.
And then there will
be some A transpose.
Of course, there will be
some A transpose here,
and some A here.
And up here I'll have
a balance equation.
OK.
I just want to think,
what's the operator A?
If we can focus
on that question,
then that's what's going
to occupy us for, certainly
the whole of next week.
So I've actually used
the word gradient.
We have functions
of two variables.
We're looking for the
change, the rate of change,
the steepness of
those functions.
So this A, Au, is going to
give me two derivatives.
I've got two variables, there
are two first derivatives.
Both of them are important.
That's what the A is.
For the next big
example in the course.
The final major
example of the course
is, when A acts on a
function of two variables,
because I'm in a
region in the plane,
to find its rate of change.
And this is called the gradient.
The shorthand is
the gradient of u.
So we have to understand that.
We have to understand
what the gradient is.
And, of course, we want
to know its transpose.
So can I just think,
what should be
the transpose of the gradient?
OK.
I'll take that picture out.
Thinking now about the
transpose of the gradient.
OK.
So A itself is, you could
say, is d/dx and d/dy.
You notice how I'm
separating out A from Au.
When this acts on
a function, this
is the gradient operator
that acts on a function, u,
to produce du/dx and du/dy.
OK.
Now what's the
transpose of this?
OK.
You can guess what it
should be, and then we'll
see that yes, that
guess is correct.
So what should A
transpose look like?
If there's any justice, A
transpose should be-- OK,
this is two by one.
The transpose you would expect
to be a row, a row vector.
I should have the
transpose of that there.
And what is the
transpose of that?
Just tell me.
Because we have an idea.
What should be the
transpose of d/dx?
Negative d/dx.
And what should be
the transpose of d/dy?
It should be negative d/dy.
Those are two different pieces.
This is not run together.
There's a big space in there.
That's two pieces.
So what is A transpose applied
to a-- So, heat flow w.
I want to say, what is A
transpose applied to w?
You're going to see this
again, but we'll just
take these minutes to show
it for the first time.
So A transpose-- Wait a minute.
Is w a function,
or is it a vector?
Yeah we've got to get that
straight before we start.
Here's an ordinary
function, a scalar function.
Just whatever, x
squared plus y squared.
What is e?
Suppose this is x
squared plus y squared.
Let's have a specific example.
What would e then be?
It's got two components, right?
It's got an x derivative and
a y derivative. e is a vector,
[2x, 2y].
Then I multiply by c.
So this w has two components.
This has got a
w_1(x,y), w_2(x,y).
So just keep things straight.
So it's that that I want
to apply A transpose to.
So A transpose w is
minus d/dx, minus d/dy.
And everything's
coming out right
because it's applied to
a function w_1 and w_2.
w is a vector field.
It's not a scalar field,
it's a vector field.
And the result is just
what it should be:
minus dw_1/dx minus dw_2/dy.
OK, good.
This has got to come out of
integration by parts, right?
So we'll have to think: what
does integration by parts
mean in two variables?
And it's a famous formula
named after Gauss and Green.
The Green's formula, often.
But do you recognize
what I'm looking at here?
This is so important
it has a name.
And what's the name?
And then we're ready to go.
What's the name of, if I take
a vector field, like [2x, 2y].
Let me take [2x, 2y].
as a specific example.
Suppose w is [2x,2y].
That was multiplied by,
let me take c to be one.
Then what is A transpose w?
Specifically.
What am I getting out of it?
What do I get from here?
That's minus the x
derivative of the first guy,
and the x derivative
of that guy is two,
so I'm getting a minus two.
And this is minus the y
derivative of the second guy,
so that's another minus two.
So I'm getting a number.
It happens to be a number here.
I chose such a simple function
it came out to be a number.
And what's the name?
So this is minus the what of w?
Just tell me, what's
the name everybody uses
for that operation?
The divergence.
Minus the divergence of w.
So I what I'm saying
here is that this-- I'm
saying it because
somehow I remember
studying vector calculus.
And in that process, I
learned about the gradient,
and I learned about
the divergence.
But I never learned that one
was the transpose of the other.
I think, looking back,
that was criminal.
To describe those-- With
a minus sign, of course.
I learned Green's formula, but
now we'll see what it means.
OK, that's next week's job.
Have a great weekend
and see you Monday.